le 15 mars 2020 les élections
municipales se dérouler un peu partout
en france à chevreuse un peu plus de
5000 habitants étaient appelés aux urnes
pour choisir entre deux listes celle de
la maire sortante à néry le pallec ou
bien celle de sébastien cattaneo et le
résultat surprenant seulement une voix
d'écart entre les deux candidats bien
que l'abstention soit la grande gagnante
de cette élection c'est à néry le pallec
qui a été réélu chevreuse 2020 est
victime de ce scrutin
alors qu'il aurait été dû être déclaré
vainqueur au moins d'une vingtaine de
voir candidat malheureux sébastien
cattaneo lance alors un recours au
tribunal administratif pour faire
annuler l'élection le 7 juillet 2020 le
tribunal juge qu'un des bulletins pour
sébastien cattaneo a été invalidée à
tort 1014 voix contre 1014 voix égalité
parfaite
l'élection est donc annulée mais le 6
août 2020 à néry le pallec fait appel de
cette décision le 12 mars 2021 le
conseil d'état confirme le premier
jugement
une nouvelle élection doit être organisé
on savait que les tribunaux en matière
d'élection par les résultats sont serrés
sont assez enclin à annuler donc on n'a
pas été franchement surpris suite à ces
jugements le conseil municipal est
dissous et une délégation spéciale gère
alors les affaires courantes de la ville
de chevreuse l'élection municipale
partielle
elle est prévue les 9 et 16 mai prochain
une campagne électorale express en
pleine crise sanitaire
on va faire là je dirais la campagne qui
s'impose au mans avec quelques papiers
quand même en boîte aux lettres parce
qu'on peut pas se passer il y apparaît
que d'essentiel à chevreuse un peu de
visio et puis on continue nous on est
sur le terrain tout le temps on continue
donc quelques nouveautés mais c'est je
dirais que c'est une continuité c'est
hyper frustrant de se dire qu'on n'a pas
les contacts qu'on peut avoir d'habitude
c'est alors on va alors ça va être quoi
à l'ancienne le boîtage traditionnelle
et puis le côté un petit peu plus geek
un petit peu plus moderne des réseaux
sociaux les réunions à distance et on
touchera pas tout le monde et c'est
dommage des listes adapté des priorités
revue pour les candidats à la main
de chevreuse crise sanitaire oblige une
seule crainte pour les deux listes que
l'abstention soit de nouveau la grande
gagnante de cette élection